This is almost surreal to say,
but the channel recently
passed 1 million subscribers!
And I know what
you're thinking:
"just 48,576 more to go
before the next big milestone!"
And indeed, I'll hold off proper
celebrations until then.
But, you know, seeing that seventh digit really
does make you reflect on what led to this point.
And if I'm being honest,
a lot of the growth for this
channel just had to do
with some very kind people
sharing and promoting the content,
both in terms of certain specific
shoutouts from creators with big audiences,
and in terms of individuals
just sharing with their friends,
so what I want to do now is take a moment to let
you all know about a few other math creators online
who I think you
would like a lot.
There's just so much good creation that
happens under a lot of people's radars.
First up, we have the channel "Think Twice".
I honestly have no idea why this channel isn't
better known among online math communities.
It contains these really
beautifully done math animations,
and if you like this channel,
you're definitely gonna like it.
You absolutely get the sense
looking at any one of these
that it comes from someone who
thinks very visually about math.
Naturally, this often takes the
form in some very pretty geometry
or some algebraic results that
are explained geometrically,
and the focus tends to be a little bit more
short form and bite-sized pieces,
so if you ever want a quick little
reminder of why math is beautiful,
This is just a great
channel to pop over to.
Here, let me just let a couple more
of these animations just play out.
Next up, I'd recommend you check out
LeiosOS, run by James Schloss.
what I like about James is that he seems to think
first and foremost about community,
and creating content seems to be more of
a vehicle for bringing people together online.
Let me turn things over to him to explain
what it's all about, both on and off YouTube.
James Schloss: LeiosOS is fundamentally a channel about
algorithms and works with the Arcane Algorithm Archive,
an open source and collaborative effort to document every
algorithm in existence in every language possible.
We're just getting started and it's
obviously an impossible goal,
but that's half the fun.
This means that we cover a range of different
topics and here are some clips of the videos.
Any light that enters a lens leaves on the other side
of the lens with the same angle it came in with.
it's almost as if the light
never entered the lens at all,
and hence the name,
the invisible lens.
If we take any arbitrary matrix, say, the identity
matrix with zeros along the 𝑤-dimension,
the rotation doesn't
look quite right.
This is because most tesseract
depictions use stereographic projections,
which resemble the act of holding
a light source behind an object
and checking a shadow
against the screen.
Here, we divide our points into smaller packages and
use the Graham Scan to find their convex holes.
We then take the vertices from the
holes and plug them into the Jarvis March
to create a wrapped
gift of wrapped gifts.
This is, of course, just a small subset
of the types of videos on our channel.
Quickly, I would like to thank Grant for
making such amazing videos on 3Blue1Brown.
It's inspiring to see such a
large and dedicated community
attempting to understand
the true beauty of mathematics.
You guys are honestly amazing,
so even if I don't see you guys again,
please keep being such
an awesome community.
Grant Sanderson: For my part, I think it would be
awesome to see this algorithm's archive grow more.
both of the last two, at least on
YouTube, have shorter form content,
So, next, let's switch to a channel
with more of a long-form focus:
Welch Labs, run by Stephen Welch.
Now, I suspect many of you already
know about Stephen's work, for example,
the excellent series
"Imaginary Numbers are Real".
But there are many other great playlists from the
channel that you should absolutely take a look at.
In fact, one of the things I like
most about this channel is that
Stephen thinks in terms of series
rather than in terms of individual videos.
And each one of them includes clear
points where the viewer can engage
with the materials more than just
through a passive viewing experience,
often including workbooks
and associated PDFs,
so the focus really is on learning
more so than just entertainment.
To get a feel here,
let me just play some snippets from the start and then
from the end of his "Imaginary Numbers are Real" series,
which should give you a pretty good
feel for the style in the scope,
and I'll also throw in a snippet
from his series on machine learning.
Stephen Welch: Algebraically, this new
dimension has everything to do
with a problem that was considered
impossible for over 2,000 years:
The square root of negative one.
When we include this missing
dimension in our analysis,
our parabola gets
WAY more interesting.
Now that our input numbers are
in their full two dimensional form,
We can see how our
function x²+1 really behaves.
Our function does
cross the x-axis,
We were just looking
in the wrong dimension.
So why is this extra dimension that
numbers possessed not common knowledge?
Part of the reason is that it has
been given a terrible, terrible name.
A name that suggests that
these numbers aren't even real!
All right, ready?
We'll draw the same
exact paths on 𝑤
and see how they show up on our Riemann
surface as they are mapped to our 𝑧-plane.
[upbeat techno music]
So, why does our green path start out at one
location on our 𝑧-plane only to end up in another?
Simply because our green path leads
us to the other layer of our surface.
From the perspective of our 𝑤-plane, it appears that
we've returned exactly to our starting point.
But actually, we haven't.
The 𝑤-plane is just a projection; a shadow.
In reality, our path has led us to a
completely different branch of our function.
[typing]
This is a decision tree.
Right now, it's learning.
When it's done, it'll have learned
to do something very human,
something that everyone knows how to do,
but no one can quite explain how they do it,
something that is fooled
generations of brilliant scientists
with its apparent simplicity,
but practical complexity.
something that has only become
possible in the last few decades
thanks to creative solutions
in the face of huge complexity:
it's learning to see.
Let's test it out.
With the help of a
camera and a computer,
our decision tree sees exactly
how many fingers were holding up.
Now, depending on
who you are,
the fact that a machine can perform this
task may be completely mind-blowing,
not all that out
of the ordinary,
or may not even be
all that impressive.
The good news here is
whichever camp you're in,
you're in good company.
Our finger counting machine is a simple example that
belongs to a deceptively complex class of problems,
problems that arise from
thinking about how we think.
Grand Sanderson: And finally, turning
away from the YouTube world,
I want to highlight the blog
"Infinity Plus One".
The tone of the writing and the associated
visuals are both delightfully playful,
but the author James Dilts manages to get in some
pretty substantive math all while keeping it accessible.
A particularly good sequence of posts is the
one he did on relativity, both special and general,
and it's a little hard to directly feature
text posts and video forms,
but I'll leave you some links in the
description to some of my favorite posts,
and, of course, the description also has links for
the other three creators mentioned here.